SPEAKER 1: Did you
know that you can now
search every moment of every
video file in your catalog?
Google Cloud Video
Intelligence quickly
annotates videos stored
in Google Cloud Storage
and helps you identify key
nouns within your video
and when they occur
within the video.
On this episode of
Google Cloud Labs,
we'll introduce you to a
quick lab that shows you
how Cloud Video
Intelligence makes videos
searchable and discoverable
by extracting metadata
with an easy to use REST API.
You'll create a request file and
call the Video Intelligence API
to create an operation
to process your request.
You will run the operation.
When it's complete,
you can see your videos
annotated, helping you identify
key entities within the video.
Cloud Video
Intelligence allows you
to extract actionable
insights from video files
without requiring any machine
learning or computer vision
knowledge.
From our massive library
of 20,000 labels,
it automatically
analyzes video content
to identify what entities
are in your video content
and when they appear.
Cloud Video Intelligence
improves over time
as new concepts are introduced
and accuracy is improved.
This lab is part of a series
of labs called QuickStarts.
These labs are
designed to give you
a little taste of
the many features
available within Google Cloud.
Search for QuickStarts
in the lab catalog
to find the next lab
you'd like to take.
When you're ready, use this
link to take the lab we just
went through today.
And when you're ready
to sign up for GCP,
use this link to apply a
$300 credit to your account.
We want to hear from you.
Every week we'll answer a
question from our viewers.
So let us know what's on your
mind in the comments below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]